how are you guys coping through all of
this or how are you doing mentally
spiritually and just getting through all
of this actually
uh speaking for myself i'm doing really
really well it's given me a wonderful
opportunity i recognize so many people
are having a hard time i'm really
blessed because i'm able to be at home
and my daughter's been able to spend
long periods of time with me so i'm
actually very happy
and that's what it's part what it's the
silver lining right now to able to have
that time with your kids and your family
and chloe you're a capricorn like me so
happy happy
birthday how is it for you to be able to
have that extra time with your family
i mean it's wonderful it's definitely um
you know this is a hard time for
everyone but seeing the positive it's
wonderful to get to be with my mom and
family on a consistent basis and um it's
what i've always dreamed of you know
it's not the pandemic but being with my
family having breakfast and dinner
together and it's you know seeing the
positive side i'm very blessed
and through all of this a beautiful song
was born the window in the wall is
absolutely serene and it really does
speak to the times right now uh what
does it mean for both of you to be able
to bring that joy to your fans and
release a song like this you know the
song uh found me i had no intentions of
singing again really i i had no plans of
it i you know just been at home like
everybody else really enjoying it and
then this lovely lady cindy sent me a
song she said my cousin wrote this song
so i was thinking oh gosh but then
it was a gorgeous song it made me cry it
touched my heart and i was compelled to
sing it hi peanut and compelled to sing
it with chloe so that's how it came
about
what was it about the song that made you
say i want to do it with chloe was it
the words or was it just
you felt it that this was it i felt it
you know the words and the melody
together were so perfect for the time in
the opening lines has this world
forgotten how to love it was like hit me
right in the heart and it you know it's
really true people are
losing their understanding and
compassion i think maybe the
separateness has really affected us and
we just need to start embracing each
other whether we agree with them or not
it can be a marriage a relationship
whatever it is politics whatever it is
there are many reasons for looking
through a window in the wall
olivia why did you want to take a break
was that something it was just time for
you or
well a variety of reasons i had a health
uh problem a couple years ago and had to
take time off and then kind of
discovered i quite quite liked it and
then
and then of course the pandemic has been
the last year so i i did manage to
record a track with barry gibb right
before the pandemic started on his
greenfields album but after that i had
no plans so this song just
found me
and
i wanted to sing with chloe so here we
are
and chloe you are the engineer you
produce you write you do all of it was
were you anyway hesitant on taking on
this project because you really didn't
have control it was the words were
already made for you yeah how did you
know that about me yeah this is the
she's done her research yeah wow
um
yeah my favorite part of music is being
in the studio and arranging and
producing so this is the first time i've
sung a song that i haven't written or
co-written or um you know co-produced um
and
so it was a different experience but um
i'm so happy that i did it and um just
seeing the response and and all the
beautiful messages that people have said
it's touched their heart and and
brighten their day that is just
it gets better every day um i'm really
and i love working with my mom you know
it's
it's great we're so proud because it was
number one on the itunes charts for a
week it was amazing we were like what
it's fantastic
and i'll be recording
more
oh sorry are you recording more yes in
the same studio gonna be working with
dave ah day again and then
trying to talk my mom into another
project we'll see
are you gonna do it olivia yes we'll see
we're talking about it
you know just sitting here
watching you too you could feel the
energy how much love there is between
you two and that relationship between
you two i mean chloe to have olivia
newton john as your mom i mean
it must be a gift but what does it mean
to have her as your friend as you know
your ally to have her by your side
yeah she's my mom i i i don't see her
like everyone sees her
um but what i what i admire about my mom
and
what you know
is her passion for the planet and for
plant medicine and
um
you know that's really become the main
focus and passion of my life is to
um you know we have a company that we're
all involved in as a family we have a a
cannabis farm and we're trying to you
know
sorry i get my words all jumbled up um
regenerative farming taking care of the
planet putting healthy food into your
body those are all the things that i
think my mom
that
makes her amazing and that she takes her
struggle and tries to help other people
so to me that's what makes my mom
amazing not the showbiz stuff i mean
it's great that's fantastic but
that's the like thank you baby it's all
it's all awesome but that's amazing you
know chicks in the mail
[Laughter]
she's your best friend
yes
i love that i hope that i have that with
my kids too when they grow up it is
beautiful to see you both the way you
are together and that's what makes the
song even more special uh you know
olivia you you are known for duets
you've done so many over the years
like 115 i know you have a album coming
out as well but here's i don't even know
if you can answer this question but um
what was your favorite one ever maybe
there's a story behind it but if you
could pick one performance
what would it be oh gosh that's really
difficult i've had so many amazing
duets i mean obviously um cliff richard
who started me on my career in england
really i sang suddenly with him that was
magical
in a garage he was saying it in a garage
and had to wait between the trucks
backing really so they couldn't be on
the soundtrack and john travolta v or
the one that i want both songs um
written by john farah so i'd probably
say those and of course with this one
here checks in the mail
and you've been really involved in doing
so many other things and the fact is i
just want to say thank you for opening
up the olivia newton-john foundation
fund to help cancer patients
you know when you when you do something
like that it kind of reflects about your
own life and what you've gone through
what is some advice you would give
people that are going through cancer at
this point in their lives oh gosh it's a
difficult time for everyone but if you
have cancer it's even a little more
difficult because we always have to
worry about our immune systems being
compromised especially if you're in
treatment so therefore you have to be
extra careful but i think just um
just trying to stay positive and know
that this two will pass and we'll get
through this and i'm working hard uh
raising money to do research on plant
medicine so we can find kinder
treatments for cancer that's my dream
and my husband and my goal and to study
um plant medicine amazonian herbs uh
there's there's a hundred thousand tens
of thousands of plants in the amazon
they've studied three percent of them so
just imagine the possibilities of
healing that we can find so i'm very
excited about it you gotta protect the
amazon too there's so much medicine in
there yeah exactly
how do you stay strong every day what do
you say to yourself or
do you do meditation to keep you strong
mentally and emotionally
yeah
yeah i
uh my mom since i was little i've seen
her meditate i
meditate every day i listen to a lot of
eckhart tolle and alan watts just um
being present in the body a lot of like
mindfulness and breathing and
being aware of the temperature in the
air i think it's so important to be in
your body and i think that i've learned
from my mom as well like
um talk to your body you know it
it hears you it's so alive and it wants
to be healthy so um develop a
relationship with it every morning i
tell my body i love it and i thank my
heart for beating and i thank
you know my electrons and neurons in my
brain for functioning and i really think
you know that has a huge impact on your
health and you're powerful you know
don't be afraid know that you're strong
it listens
oh i love that i love that and and being
strong uh i understand
that you're getting married that you
picked out a wedding dress uh how are
the plans going will your mom sing at
your wedding
who you want to say
she hasn't asked me and i doubt she will
ask me to see it away yeah i want her to
be able to relax maybe he'll get you
drunk and have you sing a bit
what does that mean
oh yeah i'll get it on film absolutely
but the plans are going well for you
yeah it's going to be very small you
know because of covid so very small
wedding but i have a um a beautiful
dress i've got
a beautiful dress and most importantly a
wonderful groom
waiting at the end of the aisle so
um yeah i'm going to have my little
doggies be the ring bearers
it's such a great idea
and we have ponies too so it's just it's
going to be horses sorry miniature
horses they don't like to be cool oh
sorry they hate people
[Laughter]
they don't identify that way
um
yes
i love that that's something to look
forward to and you know olivia yesterday
last night i went into this olivia
newton-john vortex and i was listening
to your music and it was just everything
there's so much you have done in your
career and and your life have you kind
of had a chance to kind of sit back and
reflect on your life and everything that
this journey has been
your soul like what
how has it been for you to kind of look
back a little bit
you know i don't very often look back
except if i go on instagram and there's
a wonderful site uh leaving newton john
videos and this lovely girl posts all
these things from my past that i i don't
remember doing or i haven't seen them in
40 50 years and i wow it's amazing and
when i wrote my book which is just come
back out on on paperback i
had to reflect on my life and remember a
lot of things that i'd totally forgotten
and i'm sure there's lots of other
stories that i did forget or chose to
forget but
i have had an incredible career but i i
do
really live in the present i don't think
much about the past unless something
comes up and the future is going to
happen when it happens but right now i'm
here and enjoying every minute
oh i love that congratulations on the
song and i'm looking forward to your
next duet and uh good luck with your
wedding thank you
you have such a lovely energy thank you
for making this so much fun oh your
energy too i love it too thank you
everyone thank you michael thank you so
much thank you love you talking to you
and say all our friends in canada
we love you canada
you